Google pourrait sortir un smartphone
pliant en 2023 d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
voit dans ces rendus 3D le format fait
plutôt penser au oppo finden je pense
que vous en pensez d'ailleurs
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires
plutôt carré un grand écran intérieur de
7,69 pouces avec une caméra qui est
légèrement en haut sur la bordure
déporté sur la droite et on va du coup
qu'on a des bords qui sont assez grands
je sais pas si c'est vraiment la bonne
idée parce que c'est l'aide Sud devrait
aller Google je suis pas convaincu je
suis plus pour venir agrandir les écrans
quitte à bien mettre les caméras dans
des poinçons à l'extérieur on aura un
écran pour le coup de poinçonné de 5,79
pouces j'aime bien le format je trouve
assez grand ça c'est plutôt bien fichu
en tout cas plutôt bien pensé si c'est
réellement ça qui arrivera l'année
prochaine et à l'arrière on retrouve
vraiment le design des pixel 7 qui sont
sortis il y a pas très très longtemps et
on voit on aurait trois caméras alors ce
ne sont que des rendus il y a pas
d'annonce on a des rendus photo rendu
vidéo mais en règle générale ils
arrivent quand même à sentir la tendance
c'est ce qui pourrait arriver l'année
prochaine si Google et ce smartphone
pourrait s'appeler le Google pixel fold
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez dites
le moi dans les commentaires